the medical chapter to me was one of the
most terrifying to write there are so
many instances in big ways and small
ways that this woke infestation through
I mean we talked about a little bit with
the licensing with med school
applications uh at a conference for for
you know neonatal doctors they canceled
a panel That was supposed to sort of
teach doctors about the latest
technology for uh premature premature
thank you premature babies and they
canceled the panel because there weren't
enough women and people of color on the
panel so given the choice between
educating doctors in the latest
technology or being woke they decided to
be woke yeah and so all of these things
have an impact on medical Innovation and
it's it's it doesn't end in a good place
and so that's that's the stuff that
scares me
thank you
where are you at now like in terms of do
you think that you know the seven
percent versus the 93 like are things
changing you know I know we have our
very microcosm version of it in Florida
which feels very disconnected as I said
and the thing we did the other day to
the governor it's like my show I do all
of the craziness for a half hour and
then I finish up with 15 minutes of
Florida sanity so I have this huge uh at
odds view of the world at the moment
yeah well Dave and I are obviously in
like Florida la la land where everything
really is so much saner you know we live
in Florida
right now
100 pieces about it but I I'm so happy
about that I feel so much more
comfortable with the kids because I
don't worry about them as much I in the
book I write a lot about the Florida
Move obviously and in acknowledgments I
thank the governor and the first lady
for giving us this place of normalcy and
what I say in my chapter about what to
do about this wokeness is you might have
to move you might have to switch States
you might have to switch communities it
it maybe it's as easy as switching
schools but you you have to do this for
your kids the last word in the book is
fight and we really mean it you have to
fight for your children yeah yeah I I
mean do I have hope I I hope for our
kids our kids
sure I mean I've never met them all
right so far you know it's starting to
babble a little bit yeah I mean my
nine-year-old is going to marry her 10
year old so we're really in there for
the Long Haul we've got to line them up
but I mean
I am encouraged that a lot of parents
were horrified over coveted not just
over covet obviously but also you know
they got a peek at what their kids were
learning and they were not happy about
it
um and I think that you know test scores
hitting the news is is good and I think
that people are are recoiling more and
more in horror at those things but you
know we cover a lot of things in the
book that people don't really know about
um the medical chapter to me was one of
the most terrifying to write
um there are so many instances in big
ways and small ways that this woke
infestation through I mean we talked
about a little bit with the licensing
with med school applications uh at a
conference for for you know neonatal
doctors they canceled a panel That was
supposed to sort of teach doctors about
the latest technology for uh premature
premature thank you uh premature babies
and they canceled the panel because
there weren't enough women and and
people of color on the panel so given
the choice between educating doctors in
the latest technology or being woke they
decided to be woke yeah and so all of
these things have an impact on medical
Innovation and it's it doesn't end in a
good place and so that's that's the
stuff that scares me
um and also in the children's literature
space it is so crazy now and getting
crazier and crazier and it's because I
mean I talked this was one of the things
I talk about in the book I talked to
Librarians and editors at Big publishing
houses and they said the incentive is to
go woke because the library is buying us
in bulk and individual families only buy
us single books so you know this is this
is the situation that we have and people
assume that you know when they're in a
doctor's office they're safe or if
they're reading they're safe
and you can't assume anymore where do
you think the media plays into this
because even with what's going on now
with DeSantis going after the AP
African-American studies course because
it was teaching gender queer Theory and
did you know that Harriet Tubman was
running an underground lesbian bar I
mean like it's all so stupid but the way
they frame everything is is so
profoundly dishonest that parents
parents watch The View and they hear
them say okay they're not going to teach
slavery in Florida and then they every
it's like this systemic everyone is a
word systemic but it's like this
systemic stupidening stupid inning I
like it of everyone basically absolutely
but DeSantis manages to get past that he
manages to out talk The View right I
think that that's the the case when
given the opportunity but the problem so
I think DeSantis handles it very well
and one of I think it was and and MSNBC
asked his office for a comment and they
said we will not be commenting yeah that
was after the Andrea Mitchell absolute
lie why does Rhonda Sanders not want to
teach slavery the reason I'm asking that
question though is because you know
there was this uh the book that was
taken out so far the only book what was
it it was the gender what was it gender
Theory I remember I don't know what it
was called but yeah but they were
literally teaching kids how to give hand
jobs yeah why would you want that in a
school I mean when did you guys ever
talk to these people and were you able
to like Whittle it down to that with any
of the people that you're fighting with
like they have the the grand woke idea
but did you ever like get it to them in
that at that no we have a chapter on
sexuality yeah yeah I mean at the end of
the day all parents are bigots and not
woke enough and it is their job it is
their sacred duty to save our children
from their parents
yeah but the thing is that they're also
not having children yeah that they're
they want to indoctrinate our children
they're not having any um they're all
antenatalies yeah their fertility rates
are really low so it you know it ends up
happening that they don't have kids and
they're they want your kids to have this
information and the thing is the secrecy
is such a big part of it they don't run
on you know let's get porn into schools
they run on you know oh we're gonna have
great books in our library but then they
end up having stuff like that
what is going on with whether these
teachers are actually dealt with or not
so like when Libs of tick tock puts up
these videos of these teachers and they
clearly are they're saying exactly what
you say that they say it themselves
these are our kids they're not and they
they view themselves as the savior of
these children
are fired like I know in Florida a
couple of them have right like
I'm guessing in Montgomery County it's
probably not happening like they're no
so that in that regard it's still
strengthening in some respects yeah no I
mean it is it is part of the job
description to be woke you I mean the
number of teachers that I have heard
from who say I am not comfortable and I
don't know what to do that's to me some
of the most discouraging stuff because
what can they do I don't want them to
quit I don't want everyone to be insane
in these schools but there's there they
have to sort of abide by the
superintendent the principal the
curriculum developers and so they're
really stuck between a rock and a hard
place and they feel this obligation to
students but they know that they are
it's a David and Goliath fight uh
genderqueer by the way is the name of
the book oh yeah that's the main one
that has been taken out of the Florida
school so while the media is running
around saying 1.5 million books have
been taken out of Florida schools it's
all complete nonsense what about at the
at the race level because we've talked
about it sort of at the covid level and
a bit at the gender and sexuality level
what's going on at the race level your
kids are white supremacists well they're
Jews so that's not good I don't know if
they're white right now or not it's like
you know it just depends on the week
yeah it really does depend on
um the funny thing is that CRT was
somewhat beat back it was uh that really
hit when everybody was paying attention
and when CRT uh the concept of it was
introduced to parents they saw how
noxious it was
um and I think that that that it
provides kind of a road map of what to
do and it and the parents should emulate
that in the gender fight yeah it's a
very similar struggle I mean I think a
lot of parents of color also were
horrified by CRTs and that was a really
powerful voice because they said do not
teach my children that they are victims
do not teach my children that we have to
lower standards so that they can succeed
my child can succeed against anyone in
your school and please stop telling them
otherwise because that's what's really
you know we want to talk about racism
the racism and low expectations is
really what's harming those kids and so
those voices of black parents were
really really powerful in the fight
against CRT but I think also with the
gender stuff
it's it's a lot harder to speak up
because it's all sort of lumped together
and you're just a generalized bigot if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell